so it's sunday's statement draft time
i've got the question to determine the
first pick here we go chris simpson okay
christian mccaffrey is on pace for
493 fantasy points this season really
stats
i just read what they said
come on stats
that would break the all-time single
season record held by pro which pro
football hall of famer for fantasy
points in a season
ladainian thomas yeah you win
okay i mean it was like i was the only
one i mean i was going to say marshall
[ __ ] i caught him came to my head but i
was like do they even have fantasy at
the start i think ladainian thompson in
2006 was incredible yeah that was the
first year i played
in the current league i'm in that i
still haven't won 13 years later and
that was my best chance well danny and
thomas i saw him in person in 2004 when
the bucks we went out there and played
in the charge he's one of those guys
where you get on the field and you go
you know it doesn't look like
like like this hulking presence right
and the game started and i went man we
can't cover this guy we can't tackle
this guy he was unbelievable uh and
that's why he's in the hall of fame all
right sunday statement first round pick
i mean obvious i mean come on i'm going
with last night's game i'm sorry to be
captain obvious but the ravens i mean
they made the biggest statement of the
weekend that they're for real in the afc
that you know not only did they make a
statement on themselves they made a
statement about the patriots that they
could be beat up they can be beaten that
they're not invincible so it was almost
like a double whammy that way and of
course the patriots are still the best
team in the afc i'm not going to like go
away from that but they showed that they
have issues and this was the first
really well-rounded quality appoint
i mean a well-rounded quality opponent
that they played so um the ravens just
the way lamar jackson made some plays
the way they dominated the line of
scrimmage on both sides of the ball you
know they won the physical matchup you
know they did a they basically battled
to a draw and the x's and o's match up
and then they have guy like lamar
jackson who when the x's and o's from
belichick are great he could overcome
some of the scheme things there because
of his great physical talents so yeah
the ravens they made the biggest
statement overall you're doing that
thing again where you just pick a whole
i'm picking the whole why won't you
narrow it down
all right so lamar jackson how's that no
no you why do you back off of it see i
was setting it up because i was gonna
pick a whole team too okay good i was
gonna pick the chiefs yeah because i'm
sitting there trying to think who from
the chiefs made a statement that stands
out above anyone else's do you say tyree
killed do you say matt moore does he
have some buckets no the same chris
jones it was a total team effort defense
take down a vikings team right they've
won four games in a row right that has a
very good defense and an extremely
potent offense yeah the chiefs answered
the bell in every phase of the game and
i think one of the sneaky great
decisions by the chiefs was to put tyree
kill out there for pump returns late now
the first one dustin koch with the or
britain cocoon both colquitt brothers
were punting in the game it was britain
colquitt who puns for the vikings he
angled it right out of bounds the second
time it got in his head and he shanked
it just having tyree kill back there it
gave the chiefs the short field that
they needed to win the game so you know
what i i can get behind the idea of a
sunday statement for the whole team when
you can back it up right and i'm backing
it up with the chiefs in every phase and
in coaching in everything they did and
that was what they needed to win that
game because they still barely won the
game yeah it took a total team effort to
take down the vikings i mean agreed i
mean the chiefs you know andy reid's
managed matt moore the right way
changed a few things on offense their
defense continues to show signs of being
better and i really think that you know
they're going to be a better football
team overall when mahomes gets back this
could be a blessing in disguise when all
said and done okay i'm definitely going
no team here i'm going with one guy
because we haven't really talked about
this game yet russell wilson he made a
statement yesterday he's the leader in
the clubhouse right now for the mvp in
football and there's no other way to say
it he's got 22 touchdown passes he's got
one interception and the seahawks
defense is not very good it's not like
what we've seen in the pete carroll era
especially in the past game the seahawks
the seahawks past defense it's it
borderline stinks to a degree and
they're going to have to continue to win
with russell wilson and he showed that
again yesterday his ability to make
plays and pinpoint downfield throws
it's just extraordinary there's no other
way to say it he uh his ability to hit
lock it or dk metcalf uh but look at the
day 29 of 43 378 five touchdowns um just
truly truly phenomenal and uh i can see
why they even like you know there's the
rumors that like antonio brown that they
was on their radar well yeah because i
think the seahawks realize that their
defense is a little bit of an issue this
year they're going to have to out shoot
out people on
against some of these really good teams
and the bucks matched up with them
because they could protect and throw the
ball down the field and russell just
kept answering back they've built this
team now around russell wilson that
started after the 2017 season there were
guys there who resented russell wilson
there was always that kind of toxic
quality to the locker room that pete
carroll did a good job of keeping the
lid on but they got to a point when they
didn't make it to the playoffs last year
it was time to rip the band-aid off
built the team around russell wilson and
yeah they added josh gordon in the
report over the weekend from espn was
they did their due diligence on antonio
brown before making the waiver claim on
josh gordon so getting some help for
russell wilson building the team around
him five touchdown passes
and and incredible 22 touchdown passes
one pick so far this year i think he's
right there in the mvp conversation with
lamar jackson right with the guy and you
know i'm part of what we try to do on
this monday show is is give some
attention to as many victorious teams as
we can yeah we've mentioned to sean
watson a couple of times but hey it's a
sunday statement draft desean watson 26
to 3. they played the the jaguars
earlier this year and easily could have
lost the game it was a sluggish low
scoring like 13 to 12 right right 26 to
3 and it was texans all over the jaguars
yesterday systematic not a blowout start
to finish but a systematic smothering
and desean watson the way he keeps plays
alive he is the most fun quarterback to
watch right now yeah right now mahomes
isn't healthy right mahomes and watson
are right at the same level and and the
way that watson can keep things alive is
it's just a thing of beauty and he
relishes it he he thrives on that chris
he does i mean he's the ultimate play
maker uh you know the play is never over
with desean watson he's a great thrower
you know good decision maker
the only flaw you talk about with desean
watson at times maybe holding the ball
too long you know just waiting too long
for the big play but uh the texans are
they're on a roll and watson is yeah
he's a special special talent there's no
question and he's in that mvp
conversation too i mean another game we
haven't talked about got to go to mighty
mouse okay sunday statement christian
mccaffrey uh he's in that conversation
too in fact he's the only
non-quarterback i think we're putting in
that conversation michael thomas i'm
still putting michael thomas
he is he's a beast uh but mccaffrey just
so special to what the carolina panthers
do and yeah kyle allen we talk about him
he's doing a really good job at
quarterback for the carolina panthers
but that team and that offense revolves
around mccaffrey and what he can do he
opens up things in the past game whether
it be play action or even underneath
coverage having to worry about you know
him coming out of the backfield but norv
turner does a great job of staying
patient with the run game finding little
cute wrinkles to get him the ball in the
pass game making life easy on kyle allen
there you could have thrown that
touchdown pass to christian mccaffrey i
think um but yeah mccaffrey is just uh
phenomenal i mean breakaway speed
catches the ball can make you miss and
then runs with power i think is the
thing that we are all surprised by and
they're gonna need him because nobody
knows when cam newton's coming back you
know everybody wants to be able to peg
when cam newton will return nobody knows
not looking good and he may never be
back with the panthers again after this
season you never know what they're going
to do david tepper the owner of the team
may decide to move on he's under
contract for one more year maybe they
trade him maybe they just rip it up and
say see you later we'll see what's out
there the salary isn't crippling but if
the guy isn't healthy if he can't get
healthy and can't stay healthy i mean
just think about it all that obsession
with his shoulder
and then the shoulder is fine we think
the foot's injured right so mccaffrey
keeping that team relevant keeping that
team competitive all right i am going to
do something that many will regard as
dramatically out of character okay i am
making is my final pick
raiders quarterback derek carr whoa
whoa i didn't know you could pick derek
carr or kirk cousins in a draft i didn't
think you were capable i've done cousins
before yes derek carr had a heck of a
day yes he did
he had 20 completions on 31 attempts 289
yards 64.5 completion percentage two
touchdowns a passer rating of 116.2
through the game-winning touchdown pass
to hunter renfro needed some help from
the defense to keep the lions from tying
it up but
look this raiders team is four and four
and carr has had some good performances
this year he's had some bad performances
and it's funny because he said after the
game i had the quote here and all i have
to do is find it oh good job way to blow
this up
it was going so well here it is here it
is
just shut i'm tired you can't cousin
performing it's not prime time it's
morning just think of how bad it would
be
carr said after the game we've laid a
foundation and then jack hammered it up
about 14 times since i've been here i
hope this one stays and i think embedded
in that comment
he hopes he stays yeah right he hopes
that john gruden and mike mayok don't
decide after the season that they can
find a better quarterback because
mayhawk said when they were kicking the
tires on kyle murray and dwayne haskins
before the draft hey we have an
obligation to constantly be looking to
upgrade at every position including
quarterback so we're constantly going to
look to do that and after that
boneheaded reached the ball out with the
left hand from 15 days ago and dropping
into the end zone on the same day that
john gruden is seeing the wizardry of
aaron rodriguez that was the moment you
and i thought that gruden's like all
right i'm getting me somebody else next
well we know how gruden can be i mean
you know i i witnessed it firsthand i
mean he he he he could sign seven
quarterbacks this offseason and like the
half the half the roster will be
quarterback so you never know uh but
you're right i mean whether it was
rogers or desean watson who the oakland
raiders faced the last two weeks you
know derek carr got overshadowed by two
great talents or even matthew stafford
yeah or matthew stafford you're right i
get you so matthew stafford had a hell
of a game yesterday too but uh yeah
you're right derek carr played really
well he answered the bell in a clutch
moment making that play scrambling to
the left scoring the game winning
touchdown spreading the ball around it
really starts with that raiders offense
and their running game that's the
biggest thing they do i mean they ran
for 171 yards yesterday josh jacobs has
been a handful in that department but
when you just talk about them spreading
it around i mean jalen richard was their
their leading receiver as far as yards
at 56 but it was him renfro waller
tyrell williams marcel aitman you know
zay jones who they traded for the
buffalo bills uh deandre washington he's
getting the ball out of the backfield so
they're they're using everybody within
that offense right now and that's where
i give not only derek carr credit for
spreading it around but john gruden
keeping teams off balance with that run
game and how he's gonna use certain guys
in the past game yep uh i agree with you
completely when we return what we're
gonna do is get you ready for monday
night football before we go the sunday
statement draft ravens russell wilson
christian
i've got the chiefs desean watson and
derek carr
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports